So let's think about this again. What should the denominator look like in order
to be able to take a cube root of this denominator? We know that each of these
factors needs to be raised to a power that is divisible by 3. So we'll multiply
this numerator by something. And this denominator by something to change this,
to what we need. So we need to multiply this numerator and this denominator by
some sort of expression. When we do that, we want to get an expression inside
of our cubed root that can be simplified. So you tell me. What should this
expression be? You want to use the factor of 3, x and y and indicate their
powers. Don't include the cube root inside of this box, since I already have it
written for you outside. Keep in mind that you want all of your power divisible
by 3.